what are we doing right now cutting my
hair why
i have no idea you don't alicia
silverstone's son bear
just chopped off his long locks and
looks
totally unrecognizable ready one two
three
oh my gosh oh my gosh
there he is that's even cute here
there's one what a cutie
thank you the proud mama documented the
whole transformation on
instagram oh my god i'm totally buggin
and bear he was totally buggin too
are you nervous about this at all yes
very
i'm so excited to show it's safe to say
the nine-year-old who alicia shares with
her
ex christopher jarecki was totally
feeling himself
post-makeover and we can't help but
point out that this is a little bit of
life
imitating art cher's main thrill in life
is a makeover okay it gives her a sense
of control in a world full of chaos
the 44 year old actress revealed that
the whole thing was
bear's idea and she definitely cried
inside watching it all go down
quote no matter what though i will
always support my sweet caring and
precious little boy
in every decision he makes of course
this all comes after alicia revealed
that some kids had bullied her son about
his long hair on a bus ride to surf camp
back in september but bear he didn't let
the haters get him down
she explained that she thought for sure
he'd chop it all off after his encounter
with those bullies
but when they showed up to an already
scheduled haircut
he leaned into his long locks quote he
said
please give me a trim so i can grow it
to my waist
that's my boy he knows who he is he
loves his hair and chooses to have it
long
what are we doing right now cutting my
hair why
i have no idea you don't fans first
started asking about bear's hair
last week after alicia a noted animal
rights activist
shared this video urging fans to adopt a
turkey this thanksgiving
i think if people got to struggle
turkeys they
would be able to not eat turkeys on
thanksgiving
it's so sweet and they just kiss you
like and they're so soft yep
there's bear with his new short dew oops
my bath it looks like the apple didn't
fall far from the clueless star's tree
and when eti caught up with alicia in
april she
said he actually had thoughts on where
her iconic character
cher would be today what did he think of
clueless does he
does he ever quote any of your very
famous lines from that movie now
wow you guys talk like grown-ups
oh well this is a really good school he
doesn't quote it but he'll bring little
things up
one night we are laying in bed and he
wrote he wrote clueless part two
and what where where cher would be
and it was unbelievable what he thought
where would cheer be
according to bear she was an alcoholic
but he didn't say those words she drinks
a lot i
and maybe she's a makeup artist like a
professional makeup artist
and the way his mind was
going about it was really killing me